les chéris ya plein de gens qui me
disent qu'ils étaient la star
internationale qui en voulait à ma vie
je dis eh bien cette star elle est venue
me voir dans mon bureau juste après
l'émission puisqu'il est arrivé importe
à regarder et il ya une info à retenir
dedans vous verrez on voit vous dire ce
qu'on va faire le 17 octobre
c'est parti
[Musique]
wilkin de mort la police la police entre
est vraiment vénère mais ce micro qui se
barre mais je suis pas vraiment mais
n'est rien ce que vu ce que j'ai vu que
tu faisais plein d'émissions spéciales
pour les films j'ai vu des très bien tu
vois j'ai vu à la 2 c'est super j'ai vu
taxi libre très très bien et je me suis
demandé bon moi j'ai un film qui sort là
le fils de ma ville voilà l est où mon
émission spéciale
justement je t'en parle bah oui ben ça
tombe bien alors tu vas une spéciale
fashion spécial om je sais que tu as
peut-être aux états unis je sais que je
fréquente le bota voilà de le rappeler
il est évident qu'on respecte ils sont
certes écoles de la figure du parlement
il parle de toi ils disent que moi très
attention là et atic je parle dès
maintenant
nazif est moins une question comment ça
va la porte en bas alors fais moi une
spéciale même si je suis pas là fait une
spéciale où ne s'use pas le 17 octobre
je ferai une spéciale de son absence
je savais que je devais son amitié voilà
le racket les américains oui un hanouna
il a pas obligé je donne parfois la
sortie du film de venise a conclu le 17
octobre et pmp spéciale le flic de
belleville omar sy ne sera pas là mais
on sera quand même
[Applaudissements]